hello everybody today we've assembled
the geek squawk here to join in the
battle of the ages for brawlhalla
bro
in anticipation for upcoming tournament
with geek culture as geek not good
gamers and night owl cinematics we will
be deciding today who is our final
brawlhalla champion
and without further ado here are our
valiant warriors
[Music]
[Applause]
said
[Music]
so the ultimate champion will
essentially win some really really cool
prizes sponsored by the good folks at
ubisoft so
let's get ready to rumble all right one
more round let's practice because i
don't think we are that familiar with
totally forgotten the controls so we
have all the legends unlocked thanks to
ubisoft so let's take a look guys so you
know some of the characters here from
from rohala are essentially ripped off
from games or movies or whatnot so
you can take a guess who is who raymond
hey look is that that chick from atlanta
is not so sad
right so every single character in
brawlhalla has different stats and
everything from speed power health and
everything but we don't care yes it's
all about mashing them buttons
and seeing who lasts oh [__] wait don't
don't beat me when i'm talking god damn
it
okay
all right
oh
come on man frosties
wait we are letting the sponsor
hey hey you've come right here you come
here
that's my move let me feed you some
cereal
who's gonna be the winner for this round
[Applause]
guys
as well and recently we had a wwe event
so there's what's it called smackdown
wwe characters it's fine
so just pick your favorite wrestling i'm
gonna pick not cereal today the grim
reaper okay
to defeat
why are you gonna pay me like that guys
died
eat your cereal boys and girls
[Applause]
do the right thing
it's the pole right from when she climbs
up with the weight yes this is the one
there's the phone yes so in the actual
cannon she brought down the movie yeah
she brought down the pool
wow
how can you be guns
yep
wait
no violence in sporting matches
oh [__]
oh my god
play fair now
[Applause]
wait i don't even know who's my teammate
me oh i'm sorry it's okay
did you already are you a negative one
is that you i think so i have no idea
i'm gonna bring home the bacon oh god
wait a minute hey what joseph
i'm sorry sorry jake that's my book
i mean
yes this is a great one okay this will
be 15 minutes no no no no let's do let's
just three well let's do a full 90 yeah
like okay
with half time and everything yeah and
so uh appears me and zach came again
oh is that
yep
it's the literal soccer game oh
yes
oh
[Applause]
let's go
i get married again
[Applause]
[Music]
all right so this is the final battle in
the search
for geek squawks brawlhalla champion
and
we are going to put jake and marion to
the test to see who will come out
victorious may the best cat and
lizardmen may the best animal win yes
i'm moving
like the pre-pre-game show show sir
yeah are you two still going on
yeah
all right let's go
the actual final match apparently the
questions like chelsea really helped yes
i think
extremely educative oh wow such a simple
map it costs too long
two this is gonna be a five-hour
question so chelsea please by the way
um
would you rather live foreign
would you rather
get your partner's
[Music]
you can always change the tattoo later
but you can't get replacement
nice one well done yeah food
do you want to be a vampire in a toilet
movie yes
yes who doesn't want to sparkle in the
sunlight
[Music]
yes my answer to everything is yes
is
[Laughter]
that's so weird
if you have to live on a stranded island
and you only have one sandwich what
sandwich would it be
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
yes
[Music]
what are your favorite weapons in
the one way i put women that's great
what do you find is more central looking
on a lollipop
licking on a
ice cream pork
or eating a banana i think a banana like
me
yes
yes god damn it
good game bro okay
because he clearly has been eating more
cereal than all right
so let's give a hand to the champion of
brawlhalla
so that's all the time we have for you
today what do you guys like about
brawlhalla
we hope you enjoyed our road to brahal
and don't forget to like comment share
and subscribe
and punch the living daylights under the
bell icon
so you can get more updates on our
future videos
and also if you want to see our other
braha rivals in training check out their
videos here
and over here
yeah
don't forget to vote who will be the
athens rahala champion the link in the
description is below
last but not least stay bulky and stay
geeky
you